[Music]  on the 31st of January the UK will spend  its last day as a member state this will  be a tough and emotional day but when  the Sun rises again unfed early first  the European Union and the United  Kingdom will still be the best of  friends and partners the bonds between  us will still be unbreakable the  European Union's objective and the  negotiations are clear we will work for  solutions that uphold the integrity of  the European Union it's single market  and its customs union there can be no  compromise on that we are ready to  design a new partnership with zero  tariffs zero kotas zero dumping a  partnership that goes well beyond trade  and it is unprecedented in the scope  this is the story of old friends and new  beginning and in this good sense  long live Europe  [Music]